Okay, you have mastered the art of genetics.
You started with that Udacity course, Tales from the
Genome and you went on to more schooling, you
got a degree, you became a human genetics researcher.
And now you find yourself in this situation and
you figure that it's most likely, the allele chromosome
14, causing the microtia, by affecting the transcription, the
expression of another gene elsewhere. That this allele must
be in the non-coding region and you also realized
during you test to figure out, how you could
develop a drug to treat this, that you'd need
it to reduce the transcription of gene Y somehow. It
could directly bind the promoter, or enhancer or silencer
regions, and affect transcription or it could somehow interact
with the allele on chromosome 14. We're not sure
how, based on the information here, to ultimately affect the
overall transcription of gene Y. Now, this is a
pretty big hypothetical question here because, we normally don't try
to develop drugs that we can give to pregnant
women, to affect their development. Usually, genes that are important
in development, are important for many things, not just
one thing. And so if we start going around altering
transcription with drugs and other modalities, we really run
the risk of causing more harm than help. Either way,
these are important questions that human geneticists get to
wrestle with, and really make a difference in the clinic.